inflation taking a toll on so many this  time of year United Way of Southern  Nevada hopes to lighten that burden over  four million dollars being received in  southern Nevada for children to be  enrolled in preschool at a reduced cost  or even for free it is through the  Nevada ready State pre-k program 19  preschools have been selected ranging in  age groups some of those include  oscillero Brigham Young Academy New  Horizons preschool several YMCAs and  many more schools around the valley many  preschools do not or have wait lists  rather so it's important to check the  school status and to find the school  nearest to you scan the QR code on your  screen taking you to 8newsnow.com there  you'll find the link to apply if you  missed the QR code we'll show it for you  again right after Ted's most accurate  forecast